worth putting in in mind that and this
is sort of my pet peeve with this whole
drug and sport thing is like I mean
personally I don't really give a [ __ ] I
mean I just have bigger things I care
about than like how many steroids Barry
Bonds took to hit all those home runs
but what really does chapped my ass is
when people don't actually understand
how steroids work right like it bugs the
[ __ ] out of me when people assume that
if you take steroids you will have you
know you will hit that many you know
homeruns or you will run this fast or
lift this much the only thing that
steroid is doing is enabling you to
recover faster from the brutal work that
it takes to actually do those things so
you know all the eat if I if I shot
myself full of EPO
I mean you've probably seen Icarus right
mm-hmm I mean I thought that was I
thought he did it I thought but Brian I
foe yeah I thought prime for a bit of
really good job of showing like I mean
and he was a pretty good responder to
the EPO I think he did growth hormone
testosterone an EPO I mean you saw in
the end of the day he finished worse the
second year round because about his bike
ran an exact that's my point you see
like people don't realize like one
little thing makes all the difference
from a performance standpoint yeah he
probably would have done a little bit
better but it's not because the drugs
were in him per se it's because the
drugs that were in him allowed to train
more so the reason he was a fitter Rider
the second year was because his watts
per kilo were hired because of how much
more he trained the drugs enabled him to
train that much harder yeah that's what
it does it allows you to train harder so
you recover better so you have more
output correct but we don't want young
kids to think that the only way to do
this is start taking steroids and [ __ ]
up your endocrine system and that's no
of course not but we also want to keep
in mind like see it almost requires like
a broader discussion which is like why
do we care well we care in combat sports
because it allows you to inflict more
damage no no no I'm saying like why
would why do why'd it let's just say I'm
not a professional athlete okay why do I
actually care how fast I run or how fast
I ride or any of these other things well
because you want to brag about it okay
so maybe your weight right so maybe
therein lies the problem I mean I mean I
you know when I stopped cycling
competitively I think a big part of it
was I just realized that performance and
longevity stopped being collinear they
started to become somewhat orthogonal
they started to deviate in other words
the things that I was doing that we're
enhancing my performance and I'm not
even talking about drugs I'm just
talking training wise it seemed to come
at the expense of what I believed was
gonna make me live longer so
specifically the the thing I cared most
about was cardiovascular health now the
incidence of atrial fibrillation in
highly trained athletes is ten times
higher than that of non athletes so like
that's a little counterintuitive right
yeah why would people who have such
amazingly fit cardiovascular systems
have ten times the risk of this horrible
condition called atrial fibrillation
which yeah many people have it but not
young you're not supposed to have that
when you're 40 and it's usually
associated with cardiovascular disease
and yet people are you know showing up
with these I mean I have four patients
who have had to get ablations for atrial
fibrillation what is it ablation an
ablation is a procedure where they stick
a catheter up through the femoral artery
or in the vein and then they burn pieces
of the heart specifically around the
pulmonary veins and they basically are
trying to burn away and create or remove
the ability of the electrical system to
move in this way so what was basically
happening with with this type of
athletes heart is when your heart is
constantly being exposed to that high
stretch high ejection fraction load
you're basically stretching out the
electrical system because the electrical
system of the heart runs within its
muscles so as you stretch it out a
certain group of people and we don't
know why certain people are susceptible
and certain or not but they just develop
this this dysrhythmia so you're
soldering the motherboard as it were
yeah yeah you can effectively think of
that right you're like creating new like
lines to block the the connection